if a girl has a whole face why does the
women get to blame it on the men
pressuring her or get to blame it on her
being broken
and at 28 29 find god
and resave herself for marriage with a
husband get out of here
you have no accountability but but if a
man sleeps around and has a whole face
nobody
what a man having a whole face well you
know what if i mean they say like go sow
your wild oats in your 20s right they'll
say yeah they'll say you know go around
do your thing as a guy in your 20s but
he doesn't get to blame it on his
brokenness he it's just just that he was
corny yeah but a girl
she could say i was so broken i was so
lost and at 28 29 right when i'm running
out of time now is my time to find god
trying to find myself seriously you take
some seriously when they say no but this
is not
this is where men have to take
accountability and i mean the simpy men
who the reality is they're allowed to do
that because simpy men allow it and
usually those kind of women who find god
end up with that guy that wasn't their
plan a it was probably their plan zed
but bro that's not necessarily their
fault because if you're going to be real
yeah we already know the small
percentage of men that actually get
played anyway these men are just
grateful for an opportunity to set up to
be on the pitch you know that one's
there it's like you're the manager
called man up yeah everybody's one
minute left at added time i just want to
get out there you know like that's what
i want to i just want to stretch my legs
under my nose
sure i'll weight even though you got two
kids from two different babies that's
what i'm saying i might not touch the
bull yeah but i can boy it's another cap
you know what i'm saying so the man out
here saying you know what i've been
waiting so i'm gonna get out here and
this is what it is when they're younger
they do all the madness and then some
sucker ends up picking them up
yeah but he's happy he's not a sucker
he's happy though no but he's happy
until
his decision until until she gets the
kids and he has a sexless marriage
because she's not attracted to him that
was his decision that's it you should
have known about that before he went
into the a lot of sims don't know that
though but yeah that's what i'm saying i
think a lot of guys don't know the games
like how would they know they haven't
dealt with women but again so when a
girl when a girl comes in at 28 29 and
she says i was so broken like this was
like he believes her because he doesn't
he doesn't know these girls are crazy
because he wants to believe her because
he's desperate 20 years ago
but i think the problem is the
information's out the readily available
now yeah if you don't know that that's
on you you know that's on you not doing
your research yeah but when you're
actually in it and you've never had
everyone knows like you know when you
when you're young if you used to get in
like you know when you're 15 you have
that one girl that she's violated and
you learn from that when you're like 15
and all the olders will tell you she's
doing a magazine but you're like no i
like this girl and you learn but these
men are learning in their 30s but again
once they're married some men are told
by the elders oh she's doing a madness
and still won't listen they choose not
to listen
because their options weren't let's do
that man but this is what i'm saying
though you can't just keep saying as a
younger because you know it's on you
what you decide i think this this just
goes down to a lot of men ain't
disciplined just plain and simple yes a
lot of us we think of our willies you
know i'm saying no not a lot of us have
taken the time out again we've meant to
get to know ourselves so that you don't
remove yourself from certain situations
because cool like you said i know my
mother when i was young that when they
like their wife are not greases this
girl slept with the whole block but
because she slept with me that means
there must be something there
there must be something
you understand what i'm saying bro like
these men ain't had nothing like their
whole life they got no play they
probably spent their 20s
watching and listening to their veterans
talk about the madness they were doing
and then
and then they see a girl that they know
is out of their league now do you know
what i mean and all of a sudden she's
interested someone's like right it's my
time do you know what i'm saying so
man's gonna deal with all the nonsense
okay i think that goes to people not
knowing the value because so so when
does accountability step in now because
you guys are using totally different
terms like you're leaving out all of the
accountability when on a woman
she needs to be i don't think i am
where's it you you absolutely no we just
said that simply men need to be
accountable though we literally all said
it no you used a different term what you
said is that you said it was that
they're not disciplined
that's right accountability so can we be
like that's the scenario
the whole point is men deal with the
consequences because men get the
consequences
he's got a wife that's ran through and
there's consequences that come with a
wife that's ran through and he might
no but you're right and i'm not but the
point is that women in society can do
what they want and there's no
consequence so
no okay
let me finish so i'm saying she gets to
do her thing in her whole face and she
still gets a ring and she still gets
kids with it with a husband the man
he
when he marries a hoe she divorces him
is the consequence of a woman
the fact that she doesn't get the man
she wants what the consequence of a
woman being run through and you know
used up or whatever and then getting
married but to a guy that she doesn't
want isn't that a consequence i think
the kid is more important than that is
that a concept that's not a concept i
think it's a consequence because she'll
just leave manchester united yeah
because she's because she just leaves
him after the kids and then goes back to
the street exactly
exactly what kim done kim literally got
kanye do you know what i'm saying i've
got the four youths yeah i've got a
little mixed race babies i'm cut are you
mad and now she's with people yeah yeah
yeah
and she'll take half you know i'm saying
she'll take care of
you yeah i was literally like have you
forgotten the taking heart bro they're
not getting divorced bro i promise you
they're going to stay married i wanted
to get you what alimony is
a woman a woman gets money just for
being married to a guy for a long time
no one i don't understand you can get a
job in some cases
dr dre's wife did you see how much he's
paying for her phone bills
she was asking for more
and i don't understand because you can
get a job like why are you entitled to
his money because the laws are archaic
that's why but they're married women we
weren't talking about married women
leaving we were talking about somebody
who had been run through on the streets
that had two kids and they now managed
to find a room yeah a ring so that's
married yes so now she's married to the
dude but yeah he's not the father of her
kids
right i mean she might give him more
kids i don't know yeah
look at sierra look at sierra she's
probably going to be cool with that what
she's probably going to be cool okay
let's take with the next guy that she is
with well that's i mean look at sierra
what happened with her
so what did she do she she got ran
through by future ran through all the
rappers
finds god at 28 29 settles down with
russell wilson it seems okay for a
little bit now what's she doing she's
twerking on instagram the disrespect
yeah this man that's respectful
no she is an artist she's a twerk on
instagram when you're married
so she's not able to twerk now like
she's no you shouldn't she was an artist
well she said she said she found god so
she gave russell wilson the impression
she waited a year to sleep with him and
she gave him the impression that she was
a changed woman
now after she gets the kids and the
resources she's twerking on instagram i
think that's disrespectful as a wife
there are things you can do when you are
single that i don't think you should do
if you are married preach no so i i
think it's between her and her man and
he doesn't seem to care that she's
twerking and whenever that goes against
you and that's why okay guys what do you
what would you call him how do you know
how do you know that he doesn't mind i
feel like he just he don't have a say
like it's not that he doesn't mind like
my man's doing the offer fist i'm
telling you that's like he's not like
can i just say something he doesn't have
a say because there was a video where
she was literally getting ready and i
think i saw it yesterday also and like
she was getting ready and he was like
yeah we gotta go and she was ignoring
him
like like it's all when you're going out
with your husband you take your time and
they are gonna be like let's leave now
and you are gonna be like there's a
certain level of disrespect that
happened there yeah that only a man that
is aware can see that what's happening
could i ask you a question do you like
do you like masculine or feminine men
masculine men sure so so i'm confused so
like with what we're describing you seem
to be quite okay with a lot of the way a
lot of these women behave because do you
feel like you could behave that way with
a masculine man it's the dynamics of
being in a relationship like literally
you are going to be running late as a
woman it's gonna happen and the guy is
going to be like let's leave now and
you're still going to be getting ready
sorry so this is what we mean about
accountability all you're doing right
now is giving excuse after excuse after
i'm giving you to get away with it i'm
giving you an opportunity
for the woman to get away with the bad
behavior that she's clearly portrayed
but and it's funny because whenever
you're when i get back whenever whenever
something for the man comes up you
always try to put accountability on him
and then take it off the women because
there's yeah there's too much
one-sidedness on the woman being all
accountable and it's like but what about
the matter well i think it evens that
because society always takes
accountability off of women but it
doesn't oh my goodness okay okay
okay guys would name one double standard
outside of body count that does not
benefit women
you give me one and now i'll be able to
disprove it because
one that does benefit women we get
drinks for free we get free on the first
date we get into clubs for free
women women
like from at bars from men we get our
first first dates are free